here's my question maybe help us
understand the following for some folks
that don't follow it so uh you know in
religion you'll have um
jews will say christianity you know
they're really jews jesus was a jew so
you guys kind of took it and came out
with this niv and then changed the whole
thing
you know it's really judaism two points
right and then christians will say well
lds you know you took a joseph smith
from vermont and you took this and you
created lds and you guys went and out of
chicago eventually ended up in utah
brigham young et cetera et cetera
the seventh day all this stuff that you
hear about right muslim baha'i so
what
it almost sounds like in the crypto
community there is religions right you
got uh folks like pomp who will swear by
bitcoin and nothing else like literally
nothing else the other day i was on uh
is it natalie burnell who is a very
eloquent i was on her podcast and we
were speaking she is strictly bitcoin
not ethereum not
nothing else and then there's guys that
dabble on everything and diversify and
there's guys that just can't stand
bitcoin why don't you explain to us what
these different religions within crypto
first of all i
love the religious analogy it's one that
i use all the time so it's often you
know trying to figure out
the israel-palestine issue right like
we'll we'll never see those two groups
likely come to an agreement on oh okay
we all agree this is all going to work
not going to happen but
the thing with bitcoin that people don't
understand is that bitcoin is capable
of being everything to everyone and
that's really how it was designed it was
designed
fundamentally to replace the internet we
don't have 10 000 internets we have one
internet it is a fixed protocol that
people can build on in above around but
you know the internet's going to be
there so you can build your business
based on knowing that the internet is
going to be the same
in five years and 10 years whatever
these are at least the assumptions that
we make the problem with all these
different protocols with ethereum is a
great example ethereum hardworks
basically once every year has a very
deep and fundamental protocol change
which means everybody needs to retool
everything everybody needs to reissue
tokens they need to reissue the apps
that they make they need to reissue
these smart contracts basically breaks
everything and then at the end of the
day ethereum is only really capable of
about 15 transactions per second
globally which is nothing this is
essentially zero throughput 15
transactions per second globally correct
okay got it visa for example is good for
about 50 000 per second per second so so
let me ask you this does ethereum have
the ability to improve that or that's
the limit like they claim to uh and
they're about two and a half years
behind on their roadmap saying that they
absolutely will but i i think it's i
think it's a big meme i think they want
to continue to pump valuations it's like
tesla it's like hey man these trucks are
coming out you know in in 2019 no
they're coming in 2012 well okay it's 20
21 we'll probably get them by 2020. but
you look at tesla's now trillion dollar
evaluations so
should they be you have to know this
from my end the one thing you need to
know about this group i don't know about
him but i'm not we're i'm not tied to a
group i'm just simply asking a question
to get smarter right so to me when you
talk to the metaverse community or the
uh nft community they'll say you know i
don't know ethereum's got 10 million
coins i don't know the exact number what
it is but give or take is what i hear
it's it's actually and endless so so
ethereum is emitted constantly forever
so there is no supply cap on ethereum it
exists specifically to launch smart
contracts that are
that's the key right so the smart
contract is what i love about ethereum
personally like so much of this is
currency and we get into like the the
speculative investment because so much
money is being made and lost but you
said it before it's really technology
that people don't understand the
blockchain specifically is the future of
all commerce so but what people don't
understand is that bitcoin was always
capable of smart contracts and smart
contracts that are more powerful than
ethereum smart contracts ethereum is
limited by
it's a very fundamentally different
uh
design they they use a gas model and and
this is why the fees
are astronomical
and all this stuff so in bitcoin
nodes are competitive whereas so every
node in ethereum needs to cross every
threshold together so the network is
only as fast as the weakest node in the
network which in my opinion it's an
altruistic system which in my opinion is
garbage you should never build
a network that is based on altruism so
everybody's trying to
placate everyone have it have it so that
everyone can run nodes this is why they
want to switch to proof of stake like
well we'll get more people to run more
nodes that'll be good and i think the
exact opposite i would rather have 10
people who are ruthless and really
really want to scale really want to
disrupt everything and are willing to do
anything to make that possible and
that's how bitcoin's designed bitcoin
uses what's called the utxo model
which allows them to parallelize and
compete so rather than having one chain
that is is jumping to each block you
have maybe hundreds maybe thousands of
nodes that are competing to build the
best block and they want to orphan
everybody else they want to force
everybody to go their direction because
they're the best who's this this is any
one of them this is the way the bitcoin
protocol is designed so so
right now it could be anybody and it
could change on a dime in fact this is
why we've seen you know these fiefdoms
grow up in bitcoin and then crash down
and it's because it's like look man i'm
just better than you and if you can't
keep up if you cannot be better than me
you lose and you should lose and that's
what makes bitcoin great so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]